morning hello uh great great Jets jab
pumped already um how many people here
actually don't know that much about me
or have any idea who I am
please raise your hands all right that
[ __ ] hurts
tough start okay cool
since it's about 50% which first of all
I appreciate getting 50% to know who I
am is actually pretty good so I will
apologize to the people that know my
spiel and I'll give a little bit of
five-minute context on my backstory for
half the crowd that doesn't know who I
am and then because so many of you do
and because I can speak pretty quickly
I'd like to go into as much Q&A here as
possible because the truth is I think
that's where it gets dramatically more
interesting after you've context of who
I am and listen to this you'll be able
to go to youtube and watch other
keynotes I've given and so I think at
some level context is what I'm most
passionate about in the context is we're
here together in real life and the
content is fine but I think the
engagement will be dramatically better
so let me spiel my thesis try to
incorporate it into your world and then
we'll go into Q&A so you can ask me
about what actually matters to you under
that theory I was born in Belarus in the
former Soviet Union I came to the US
when I was three we were very poor I
lived in Queens New York in a studio
apartment the size of this stage my dad
got a bunch of side jobs there was a
very ghetto lifestyle we had a hundred
bucks kind of thing it was super
interesting
my dad eventually got a job as a stock
boy in a liquor store in in Clark New
Jersey we moved to Dover than Edison New
Jersey and when I was six I started my
entrepreneurial career it was an Edison
New Jersey where I started my seven
lemonade stand franchise now convincing
your six year old and 7 year old friends
to stand behind a lemonade stand the
whole day and basically you're skimming
90% of the profit is a fairly solid
business model
do you guys remember big wheels those
little bikes I used to ride my big
wheels at the end of the summer days and
pick up my cash for my seven locations
like I was little Tony Soprano or
something so that was my first business
that was good when I was 12 I started my
first substantial business for anybody
in here who's like 35 to 42 you may
recall that during those years baseball
cards have become a huge phenomenon in
in the American Society I jumped on that
bandwagon and I started a baseball card
business and when I was 12 I was selling
13 14 15 I was selling baseball cards in
the malls of New York and New Jersey and
I was making two to three thousand
dollars a weekend selling baseball cards
and you know the way I kind of look at
that era for me is when you have $30,000
in cash under your bed and you're 13 and
you're not selling weed you're doing a
good job that was good that was you know
in some weird way like my ambition is to
buy the New York Jets which is gonna
obviously cost me several billions of
dollars I still believe in my heart that
I will never be more rich than when I
was 13 and at 30,000 in cash I mean
Nintendo was like 200 bucks right so
that was that then I turned 15 1415 and
my dad ruined my life my dad at this
point very much my entrepreneurial hero
came this country with no money and no
language and at this point now owns his
own liquor store in Springfield New
Jersey small shop that he now owns and
of course first generation oldest son
I'm dragged in and have to be a part of
the family business which I was happy to
do the problem was I went from making
$2,000 a weekend to making $2.00 an hour
15 hours a day bagging ice in the
basement of my dad's liquor store I call
those two years the dark ages you know
go that was tough blow you know getting
thirty bucks a Saturday instead of 2,000
hurts your heart especially when you're
a kid and you know like any young
entrepreneur I thought everything that
my dad did was wrong I had a lot of
different ideas and when I was finally
17 and allowed upstairs
from the basement I started looking for
the angle that could create a passion
because the truth was my dad's store was
called shoppers discount liquors and I
had no interest in selling Coors Light
an Absolut Vodka a dead cost which was
the business model and I just wasn't
interested on a faithful day everybody
came in and asked for the same wine it
was the camus special select 1991
Cabernet Sauvignon Wine Spectator which
is the holy magazine of the wine world
had named it the wine of the year and 30
40 50 people came in asking for that
wine everybody coming in and leaving
because we'd sold out I decide there
that the next person that is going to
ask for it I'm gonna create a back order
for it we didn't have a back order
system but that was okay because I was
going to school on Monday and would have
to deal with that [ __ ] anyway so guy
walks in goes do you have the cameras I
go no we've sold out but I'll take a
back order what's your name you know
I'm like okay great your address phone
number I go how many bottles would you
like and he goes well I'll take six
cases if you can get it and I was like
oh [ __ ] an alcoholic
I was like six cases I'm like are you
throwing a party he said no I collect
wine that was it
when he said that I mean you know when
you'd like hear a song or like smells
something you can literally be brought
back to a moment like I'm literally
standing here right now telling you this
story can literally feel the way I felt
in the Chardonnay section of my dad's
liquor store when that happened because
that was the moment that my life changed
because when I said I said you collect
wine and we got into a 5-minute
conversation about wine collecting and I
realized right then and there I was like
Frank Thomas Ken Griffey junior Wayne
Gretzky Michael Jordan silver oak Opus
one Camus Chateau Lafite same [ __ ] you
know and basically I took all my passion
of learning every stat to my passion of
learning every stat in the wine world
and no seventeen-year-old child should
know as much about burgundy and the
Rhone Valley as I did but I went all-in
as a complete DMF student I would spend
all my time in school reading about wine
my junior and senior year of high school
because I knew what I was gonna do I was
gonna open up 9,000 wine shops across
America sell the franchise and buy the
New York Jets right so that was the plan
and I did nothing other than creep
behavior to do that and then I went to
college and in my first semester my life
changed again
I was playing Madden 94 dominating by
the way he's playing Madden 94 my friend
runs in and says hey you have to see
this I'm like cool finish off the game
going to go into the room by the way
Madden 94 was the first year they did
old-school teams the reason I was
dominating was the 69 Jets Namath to me
nerd every play was unstoppable anyway
walked in my friends room he's sitting
in front of a computer now at this point
I'm a freshman in college I had never
owned a computer I probably at this
point I'm now 18 years old I'd never
owned a computer I had probably spent
twenty minutes on a computer in my life
I had a word processor that I was
supposed to write my papers on that I
never wrote and now I'm sitting in front
of a computer and my friend Tokyo Joe
looks at me and he says yeah I know he's
the best he looks at me and I look at
the computer I mean this is hell insane
and the fact that this is 20 years ago
which is long but not really I look at
him I'm like oh is this the information
superhighway I mean remember like that's
literally what we called it for some of
you youngsters he's like yeah and it was
the first time I heard the couch
remember nap sound dial-up when AOL was
charging us the Reeboks a minute to be
on the Internet talk about a real
business right and then he looks at me
and he says the words that changed my
career he gets on the line AOL and he
looks at me and he goes we can get
chicks on this thing
and I was like yes it's like okay here's
what gets really ridiculous I wait three
hours because I was sixth in line to
play on the Internet and I stood there
for three [ __ ] hours watching people
be on the Internet I finally get my turn
and within 20 minutes the first thing I
did I saw there was a search tool and
within 20 minutes of being on the
internet I found myself on a bulletin
board selling baseball cards and comic
books and right then I knew for the
first time at 13 9000 baseball card
stores sell it by the Jets at that
moment prior to that moment 9000 liquor
stores sell it by the Jets and now I was
looking at something and I realized holy
crap I don't need to open up 9000 liquor
stores and I started the learning
process twenty four months later I
opened up launched winelibrary.com it
was the second ecommerce wine business
in America two years later I came home
from school and I took over operations
of my family liquor store business I
grew my family wine shop I rebranded it
from shoppers discount liquors to wine
library and from 1998 to 2005 in a
seven-year window I grew that business
from a three to a sixty five million
dollar business this is where gets
relevant to you the only thing I'm good
at the only reason I have the luxury and
honor to stand in front of you and have
your attention right now the reason I'm
allowed to do this is the ironic thing
is unlike many of you I suck [ __ ] at 99%
of business things I'm not that good at
it there's plenty of things I'm very bad
at but there's something I'm really good
at and one thing that I'm really good at
is recognizing that way too many of us
in this room try to work on our
weaknesses instead of quadrupling down
on our strengths I've never tried to
work on my weaknesses
I've only a text or 40 X or 100 X to
what I'm good at
I triple down I could example down it's
why I accepted being a DNF student what
I'm really good at and what I want to
talk to you guys about today is the
thing that I've spent my whole career on
the reason I
built that business to a sixty million
dollar business the reason that I in
2009 when I decided to build my personal
brand and write books and speak that I
was able to build very quickly in a
three or four year window and be one of
the prominent figures in that space the
reason that over the last three years in
launching vaynermedia my social media
agency b2b business that I've been able
to grow it from a 20 to 400 person
organization and from a 3 to a 45
million dollar business in that time
period the reason I've been able able to
do all that stuff the reason I invested
in Twitter and Tumblr in 2007 and
Facebook in 2008 and over 4 years ago
and all the money that I make all the
business good stuff that happens to me
it's all predicated on one thing my
friends the biggest thing that separates
me from a lot of people in this room and
in the world my advantage the number one
thing I see from the Facebook's and the
Twitter's and the ubers and the birch
boxes the number one thing that I see
now that I have perspective and having a
hundred clients that do billions of
dollars in their fortune 500s the
startup entrepreneurs that I meet small
businesses because I care about that
groups like this there's only one
differentiator there's one thing I look
for and every one of you if I'm going to
do business with you
or invest in your thing or have you as a
client the one differentiation the one
thing that's gonna separate every single
person in this room going into 2015 20
19 20 22 the number one thing I'm
looking for is what I'm really good at
is marketing in the year that we
actually live in and I'm gonna let that
sit for dramatic pause okay
the biggest problem right now and / the
biggest opportunity right now and by the
way the entire rant I'm going into over
the next 40 minutes is gonna be
predicated on hoping to get one or two
of you to actually do what I'm talking
about because I'm real practical you're
about to get really [ __ ] pumped for
the next 40 minutes but then next
Tuesday happens right and then you don't
do what I'm about to talk about and so
what I'm trying to do very honestly I'm
being really open right off the bat I'm
looking for one or two people looking
for one or two people in this room to
understand what I'm talking about to
understand what is actually happening to
understand that the Internet is the
biggest culture shift in our society
since the printing press we are
currently living through the Second
Industrial Revolution that everybody in
this room including me who fancies
himself to know what the [ __ ] is going
on is grossly under estimating the
technology and culture chefs that we're
living through right now and that within
that there is an enormous opportunity an
enormous danger depending on what you
decide to do do you in this room run
your business like it is June of 2014 my
gut with all due respect is you do not
because I watch it every single day as
we completely disrespect the fact that
communication communication in our
society has been shifted forever we are
living through the single biggest
culture shift you know why I built wine
library from a three to sixty million
dollar business while everybody was
confused what that kid was doing was
because when Google AdWords came out I
bought the word buy wine and wine and
Cabernet and I owned the word wine for
ten cents on Google for nine and a half
months before anybody bid me up that's
why you know a house because while every
other idiot was making a catalog and
shipping it to you in the mail in
nineteen ninety seven eight nine I
started an email service when the first
customers I asked hey do you have an
email that like yeah I do
I'm like I like to join you from my
email service this was being done in the
store I'm like what's your email they're
like AOL at yahoo.com I'm like
that's how I was asking for email in 97
so while everybody was spending $4
printing their catalog to tell you the
new this was out and then two bucks to
ship it by the time you got it I emailed
you 90 days 150 days earlier and you'd
already bought it and I spent no money
on that email
other than the time had spent me to
write the email and then in 2003 when
banner retargeting cookie ads came out
right and everybody when people thought
cookies were the [ __ ] you put in milk
you know I was doing that and realizing
jeez if I follow you around the internet
with my banner ad eventually being like
fine I'll buy your [ __ ] wine right
and then in 2006 and then in 2006 three
months four months after it launched
when everybody was like what's YouTube I
started a YouTube show and that's where
my career really kind of took a turn
what happened was I saw YouTube and I
was like jeez this is really a game
changer I went all in at this point I'm
running this business and now I'm
starting this wine show where I'm
sitting in front of a camera and I'm
tasting wine and the first 80 episodes
I'm petrified that I'm gonna lose my
clients cuz you know like it was such a
new medium and I didn't really want them
to know what my true personality was and
all the things I really cared about and
so I was kind of still doing my thing
but then right around episode 87 I kind
of be felt comfortable and became myself
everybody thought I lost my mind
everybody in my organization including
my biggest advocates thought I lost my
mind cuz I was spending an hour taping
this show and it was on this thing
called YouTube and you know 18 months
later everybody thought I was a genius
because it started emerging as an
important platform this was 2007 and
eight and then it took another two or
three years for most people in here to
even know what YouTube was or care about
it when you're early there's a land grab
while many people sit around and try to
look for the numbers and decide what the
ROI is of something the action is
happening and you know when I hear
people say Gary there's a lot of risk
and me jumping into vine or snapchat
right now and I said to myself my god
there's so much more risk for you not to
and so its offense or defense right it's
not complicated what I'm confused by
though is that people aren't living in
the world
we actually live in because the other
thing is this how many people in this
room by show of hands signed up for
living social or Groupon
two or three years ago during its heyday
raise your hands raise them high don't
[ __ ] me good 70% so all of you
remember three years ago how you
couldn't [ __ ] wait to get $40 worth
of sushi for 20 bucks right how was your
best day to get that email for $80 nail
treatment for $40 right you remember
that how do you like those services now
you don't because the number one thing
that I know more than the Sun will come
up tomorrow is that marketers ruin
everything it's what we do and so it's
true guys when I saw snapchat I couldn't
wait to [ __ ] up that little ghost I was
pumped I was like cool all the kids are
gonna be on that I'm gonna figure out
how to sell them [ __ ] that's what we do
that's how our brains work right and so
that's what how many people here who
have done email marketing or involved in
email marketing with an organization or
have historically been involved with
email marketing at any point in their
career just raise your hands
awesome so for some of you like you know
new timers in email marketing in 1998 I
had 400,000 people on the email service
of winelibrary.com
and I had 89.9% open rates yeah and 71
percent click-through you know why cuz
marketers hadn't ruined it yet because
email how many people had email in 1998
and we're using it this is fun remember
remember remember how you read every
[ __ ] word of every email in 1998 you
did it's just the way we did it
marketers hadn't ruined it yet spam
hadn't come along the tactic of putting
your name in the copy but it was like a
different font and color that didn't
make you feel good I mean you feel like
[ __ ] you know like all that and so like
that is what happens my friend said
everything I believe in everything I
believe in right now Facebook dark posts
Pinterest everything I believe in that
drive business results right now will be
ruined by 2019 they'll be more expensive
and less effective and that's the cycle
of every single medium in the history of
storytelling and that's the way it works
and so
I continue to be confused by people that
debate what's going on
while it's going on then finally jump in
and believe in it and are getting
diminishing returns and that's why I'm
able to make money because I'm a fast
mover because I'm not crippled by the
notion of being wrong if the platform
doesn't hit and most of all because I'm
confused by this room and everybody else
when they say well how do you know which
ones to jump into I don't know how about
the one that went from zero to a hundred
[ __ ] million users in two minutes how
about that one I mean people are always
like you're only so right like you're
like I'm always like I'm not Nostradamus
I'm like I just live in the world that
we actually live in I was in a meeting
with a fortune 500 CEO who does 1.3
billion dollars in sales to 12 to 19
year old girls and I gate went through
my entire 2015 plan for his business I
said look we have to shift a lot of our
money into Instagram and snapchat and
vine right and he sat through the whole
thing I gave him all the numbers all the
stuff that I think most of those guys
like like numbers and [ __ ] right all
that good stuff I did all the right
things I did it in corporate way because
I really want him to do it because we
really affect his business they'll be
really good I was really excited and
then the guy goes he goes Gary listen
this was great he goes he was my problem
he goes you know I don't really get
Instagram and I said that's nice dick
that's his name that's his name I'm
sorry that's the thing really it is oh
that's nice dick I go but the problem is
200 million of your customers do the
amount of people in this room who have
made a romantic decision on not changing
or evolving because of the way they grew
up or the way it is or the one that I
pisses me off the most
the way it's supposed to be really your
[ __ ] God you know the amount of
people that sit in this room and clearly
if you're in this room you're winning
your leader you're thinking about this
stuff you give a [ __ ] you're trying
you're hustling you're winning and the
amount of people even in this room
forget about the masses even in this
room that have made an emotional
decision the people in this room who've
drawn a line in the sand because they're
scared of going on the other side of it
because they don't know it or because
they're comfortable in the way they've
done it the single best way to go out of
business my friends is to be romantic
about how you make your money I see it
every day and so have you and here's
where I get really scared here's the
problem you've seen dudes like me before
you've been to conferences like this
before where the guy comes up and says
this is coming I was this dude in 1996
as a kid I stood in front of a YPO event
and said by the year 2000 all of you are
gonna come into stores with phones and
take pictures of the product and it's
gonna show you every price of the
product and this way price is now
becoming the game all of you need to get
into price and the rise of private label
this is the game well here we are 14
years past 2000 and that is still not
behavior outside of a little bit of Best
Buy Amazon dynamics so you've seen what
I'm talking about
you've heard in seminars and in
organizations and people pitching you
books through the years of this is
coming if you don't change you're [ __ ]
and then you live and nothing happened
and you start becoming cynical to the
message and you're right
here's what I'm most [ __ ] scared of
what we are seeing now with the maturity
of the internet because the Internet has
now hit a 20-year age and I know there's
some nerd in the background actually
Gary 90
that he's I know [ __ ] nerd but I mean
normal people normal people started
getting on the internet with Windows 95
right
normal people started getting on the
internet with Windows 95 and now we're
at 20 years now we've got a generation
that grew up with it right how many
people in this room do not remember the
world pre-internet and I don't mean your
memories a little shitty I mean you're
young do not remember the world
pre-internet one two three four five six
all right six people - were lying for
sure because we've got six people in
here do not remember the world
pre-internet right think about that it's
just starting and so what I'm scared
about is what I'm gonna rant about for
the rest of my time and you listen and
you're gonna say my favorite things my
favorite well my customers my customers
they're not on those things right that
doesn't matter to me because my
customers are not on these things how
many people here in this room have a
fourteen to twenty two-year-old child
raise your hand 14 to 22 perfect good
amount to all of you you remember this
conversation three years ago
hey little Ricky hey little Susan I
don't give a [ __ ] how you talk to your
friends but when your mother and father
call you pick up the [ __ ] phone
remember that
just curious how'd that work out for you
and the reason we're laughing for the
people that don't have children knows
age groups let me explain exactly what
happened there are a grown-ass men in
this room who in the last 24 hours
have texted lol and oMG and little Ricky
and little Susan are not such geniuses
they just have technology on their side
and they're dragging us down my friends
we are living through the unification of
our society if you look at the data of
the behavior of the people in this room
you will be blown away if you look at
the average behavior of a 43 year old
woman her behavior and what she wears
how she goes out what she buys how she
communicates maps to the average 29 year
old woman just ten years ago it's
incredible the fastest-growing sector of
selfies are 40 to 50 year old women who
were selfies guys if you are fortunate
enough to be in this room and you
remember your parent at your age if you
are fortunate enough to be sitting in
this room right now and had the luxury
and the luck of knowing your parent at
the age that you are now please for one
second think about them do the math of
how old you are please think about your
parents right now
at your age I promise you they were a
lot older than you are
the things they were doing the way they
were hanging was much older and so
what's happening is we have a rule of
professionals in this room who say well
my well my customers not on Facebook or
Instagram maybe they're on LinkedIn
right my customers not on this that is
the exact same rationale that Netflix
put blockbuster out of business with
blockbuster sat a room and they said our
data shows right now that people like
going to our stores yeah thank you can
you come with Mike can you come and tour
with me I could use that laughs in that
moment by the way are you really ready
laughs here's what the report actually
said they liked the experience of going
to our stores because they
the ability to open and close and read
the back of the DVD cases gets better
they enjoy the serendipity of possibly
running into their neighbor this is what
the report you know by the way that's my
favorite part about reports and data
when you have an agenda you can make a
report do anything you want thank you
and then finally they really like
picking up popcorn on the way out I
don't know about you guys but here is
the experience I like laying naked in my
bed and pressing one [ __ ] button
every magazine rag in marketing right
now is talking about the demise of
Facebook at age can't get enough
articles out about organic reaches
dropping startups and a food blog wrote
an article breaking up with Facebook
here we are in June of 2014 I stand
infront of you to be historically
correct so you look back at it and say
Gary was right no other reason because I
don't really want to share with you my
secrets but I'm lucky enough to know
that 99% of you are not gonna take my
advice anyway and thus I'm just going to
be historically correct and continue to
build my brand which is why I'm about to
tell you what I'm about to tell you you
like that one you like that set up it's
just true it's [ __ ] true it's
ridiculous at this moment right now if
you haven't heard this term please write
it down I see some of you writing it
down there's something called Facebook
dark posts the official term is Facebook
unpublished posts it gives you the
ability to no longer worry about
building up your Facebook page and then
pounding those people it now gives you
the ability to go on the backend of
Facebook and target every single person
on Facebook there's long tail as you
want with data that I've never seen or
could conceive before because not only
is it Facebook data but it's data coming
from the outside world you want to sell
our used car how'd you like to go in
somebody's feed with your ad or piece of
content who's used their triple-a card
three times this month because then you
know for those 1,700 people you could
write something like are you pissed at
your car [ __ ] yes and so we're living
through a moment right now gene 2014
where Facebook dark posts are the best
conversion D our conversion forget about
branding and engagement the best
conversion product that I've seen since
Google AdWords in 2000 and yet all my
contemporaries lots of the other social
media experts definitely the advertising
medium continues to pound and say
Facebook down organic reach down and I
just sit there and laugh and I sit there
and laugh and remind myself my god
thank God I've stopped talking about
every other subject besides social media
wine and the Jets because if this is
what I sound like when I talk about
healthcare and politics and food then
[ __ ] I'm never talking about it again
and that's what I mean we have a lot of
people a ton of people who want to be
pundits and very few that are
practitioners said my friends just
what's going on every single day that if
you are marketing in this world and you
do not realize that Instagram right this
second is the new Facebook that
everybody from the ages of 13 into 40
put their attention to this platform but
that you cannot functionality-wise have
a link out from your piece of content
which then cripples people with the
notion of well how am I gonna track its
value while I sit in [ __ ] rooms and
they're arguing with me how am I gonna
track the value of this Instagram piece
of content while they pour millions of
dollars into print and outdoor media
that are doing the same exact [ __ ]
thing except it's doing it for a world
that doesn't exist anymore
my friends do you know that who here has
run a print ad for their business or
runs print ads in any magazine of sorts
or newspaper for your business I do who
does raise your hands
do you know us suckers that just raise
their hands that we're paying eight
times the circulation of that
publication just in case riki leaves
Sports Illustrated or the Philadelphia
Inquirer on the [ __ ] train and Johnny
comes along and looks at it we're paying
eight times the circulation because that
articles gonna be read eight times by
people and if you think anybody's
getting to page 137 where you're one
fourth pad is in the bottom left corner
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
guys do me one favor when you leave this
conference when you get in your car and
you drive I want you to look at five
people five when you leave this
conference to be one favorite one you
want to do me one favor look at five
people when you're driving on your way
home out of this conference I promise
you here's what I know
that I did billboards all over 78 the
Jersey Turnpike I did billboards my
whole career I like Bill Moore
it's grand it made my brand big right
there great but look every single
passenger and those five people if
there's a passenger I promise you is
looking at their phone so you're telling
me that a billboard in 2014 June 2014 is
as valuable as it was in 2006 it's not
because that same passenger used to just
sit there and kind of like they're in a
conversation but they may be passively
saw those images I've got something
scarier of the five people you're gonna
look at three of the drivers are looking
at their phone guys I'm literally
because I do it for marketing it's
actually changed my behavior I actually
now drive my car with two hands for the
first time since I was 17 years old
because I'm so scared of you [ __ ]
so my friends you think that a billboard
is worth multibillion-dollar industry
you think billboards are is valuable in
2014 my friends people aren't looking at
billboards they're barely looking at the
[ __ ] road and that's where we're at
commercials my clients spend billions
billions of dollars how many people in
this room in this year in 2014 are
watching everything outside of live
sports and live events shows on their
time DVR TiVo Netflix on-demand HBO GO
please raise your hand if you watch your
TV consumption or movie consumption when
you want to watch it in one of those
formats raise your hands and don't get
lazy because I want to get a real sense
talking about 85% of this room maybe
more just curious how many of you in
2014 have fast forwarded every single
commercial raise your hands guys
we're sitting in a room that I think we
can all agree is not a high school crowd
right and 85 percent of this room is
doing everything in their power to
escape the consumption of a commercial
in a world where they're spending fifty
five billion dollars producing and
distributing commercials and even if
you're lucky to get your commercial
through to the 15 percent of the people
here that are not doing that even if
you're lucky enough that a commercial
gets through
because you dropped your [ __ ] remote
off your bed even if that rarity happens
everybody in this room the second
something goes to a commercial goes for
their phone and checks their email or
tweets out their two thoughts on the
hood out Desperate Housewives of Orange
County or more importantly I was at a
bar I've been a big proponent of
spending money on sports television but
I was at a bar last year for the NBA
Finals and LeBron did something
ridiculous and it went to commercial and
I watched every single goddamn person in
that bar go to their phone and go to
Twitter or Facebook to leave their two
cents we live in a world now where our
customers definitely the ones that are
growing up and soon to be us as our
behavior reviewed this down we live in a
world right now where every one of us
thinks that our two cents on every
single thing is for the record publicly
we've got to add our two cents the rise
of two cents right and so when you're
leaving information you're not consuming
information my friends this is all about
supply and demand of storytelling the
supply and demand the one thing that
binds every person in this room the one
thing that binds you I have no idea what
you all individually do b2b b2c you know
whatever you do whatever bite the one
thing that binds everyone of us the one
thing in the context of businesses
before you tell me how great your thing
is before you tell me why I should jam
with you buy your thing do business with
you before that the one thing that binds
us says before you tell me your story
you need my attention and we have a very
big problem right now in 2014 in the
supply and demand of attention because
there's way more stuff and the day's
shrinking quicker and quicker and we're
valuing time more and more how many
people mystery were willing to admit by
show of hands there's a tough one so
don't [ __ ] me how many people are
willing to show and I don't want some of
you gonna do this so let's own it how
many people in this room are willing to
admit that they have now gotten to the
place where you actually get pissed off
when somebody actually calls you raise
your hand can you guys turn on can you
guys turn off can you turn off the turn
up the lights like I want everybody to
see this this is insanity and turn them
up like I want everybody I don't know if
you could turn the actual lights in here
you got to help me here as a matter of
fact this is so insane
I need this one can you guys do me a
favor I noticed a little bit of I
appreciate actually let's keep it this
way because I need the faces I feed off
their [ __ ] faces by show of hands how
many people in this room have gotten to
the place where they actually get pissed
off when another person calls them one
more time hi I want people in the front
row to look at this I want this is the
highest percentage I've been doing this
for about six months now this is now by
the way every single talk it's growing
every single talk when I did this 18
months ago I almost got booed like
people like here Peter pushing it a
little far a guy right it was like a
couple people almost half this room is
mad when another human being caused them
that is because quietly unbeknownst to
you if you're not paying attention the
number one thing you value besides the
health of your family and money is your
time and time is money as a classic
saying but this is different again
because this is not a high school crowd
and only six people remember the world
pre-internet do you guys remember
because I sure do
remember when work actually ended in a
day remember like I used to think I was
a workaholic I used to come into the
wine shop at 7 a.m. and leave at 10 p.m.
but I still had time for myself at 10:15
when I got home that game is over
everybody thinks you're on the record at
all times my employees my business
partners my investments they think if
they emailed me at 11:14 p.m. that I
should be responding at 11:15 that that
is the expectation that is what's
happening that is the world we live in
how many people have started texting or
getting texts from people saying can I
call you
[Music]
it's so interesting because you know
what happens we evolve right because
we're starting to realize this
you've become considerate I would really
take the lights back if you'd willing to
give it to me
unless I'm screwing you up because I
love the faces because we realize it
we're now becoming considerate because
we know it's a value prop I how many
people are familiar with uber the car
service uber real quick so one of my
great investments even though I passed
in the first round left a lot of money
on the table but got in a little bit
later I always say I invested not
because they were a transportation
company because they were selling people
time you know if you're in New York City
ever it's amazing there's no better
transportation there's no better
transportation and because you can get
an uber in a minute instead of a cab in
four minutes serendipitously or you
might get it in a minute even the chance
of losing time you're willing to pay
double we are living through the single
biggest cultural shift of my time and
what's happening in this room is you're
spending money and time on dumb
marketing if you cut 25% of the dumb
[ __ ] you do day in and day out because
you've always done it because it's what
you think is right or how you thought it
was or that your customer wants it this
way if you cut that 25% of dumb [ __ ] and
you invest it into where we're going or
more very honestly I'm positioning it
that way I'll say it in a different way
where we are you will win there's a
reason that the government spends on
ungodly amount of money on the military
there's a reason it spends an ungodly
amount of money on Green Berets and Navy
SEALs tanks and traditional warfare
don't solve everything you've got to
have new stuff and you've got to do your
Navy SEALs work you may think that
Twitter is dumb you may think that
Facebook's not cool anymore or who's
there or my customers not there you may
think that but every piece of data and
every growth of every company in America
over the last 18 months proves you wrong
and that's it how can I convince you to
market in the year that we actually live
in that is what I ask you
how can I convince you that the
attention of our consumer everyday goes
more here and less here and less here
how can I convince you that I'm a
networker by trait and then I use
Twitter and Facebook as a gateway drug
to get to this evening that I have
relationships with people that I see
once or twice in a blue moon
but because of the digital presence and
engagement that we have deeper
relationships than the nature of the
time we've actually spent together so
that when we actually try to do business
I closed more business because I've been
contextualizing and networking digitally
and emotionally at scale using the tools
that are afforded to me in the world
that we actually live in and so you are
more than welcome to continue to draw
lines in the sand and say not my
industry not my customer not us you're
more than welcome as a matter of fact
I'd prefer it more from me but I implore
you to start paying attention because we
are living through the biggest culture
shift of our time and if you have the
audacity to sit here and think that
things that have overthrown governments
in the Middle East that had dictators
for forty years is not something that is
affecting your [ __ ] business
then go ahead not me thank you
[Music]
thank you so much
so I left 15 minutes for Q&A because now
that's philosophy that's theory
that's my ramp that's my gospel but
practicality is what I live on please
don't let this sizzle confuse you for
the steak I will build 60 million dollar
businesses on my charisma or my jersey
mouth